Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
We have discussed throughout the
entirety of last week
in great detail
the first encounter
and the first
time the prophet Muhammad sallall.aii
wasallam received
revelation
of the Quran from Giblis.
the time, the incident when he was in
the cave
in Jabelin,
the mountain referred to as Mount Light
and the cave which is known as.
In this cave, the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam received these first
five verses.
Recite
and seek aid in your recitation
in the name of your Lord who has created
all that exists.
And he created the human being
specifically
from a drop or a collection of drops as
he mentions. And what's meant here by
drops
is a little bit bigger than a drop. It
is a tiny clinging clot.
This is referred to as a
and the word here is plural.
[Silence]
Recite
and as you recite
simultaneously no as you recite your
Lord is vast in generosity.
Your Lord who is vast in generosity
taught
by the pen.
He says
he taught the human being what he did
not know.
So these five verses
you notice here Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala did not start with
he didn't start with
recite
rather he started
and seek aid in your recitation in the
name of your Lord.
What is meant in the name of your Lord?
Bismillah
as Allah later teaches at the beginning
of every chapter.
And more broad than that, even any
endeavor of knowledge,
if a person hopes to arrive at any
reasonable beneficial conclusion,
a person must begin bismillah.
In the narration collected by many of
the scholars of hadith and almost
unanimously accepted and mentioned the
prophet Sam
said
he says every endeavor that a person
undertakes
which is of any significance
and is not started and begun bismah
then the person's endeavor will always
be incomplete
cut off
unachieved
in its entirety
any endeavor of worth anything
that is not begun bism
then it will
never reach its full potential. The
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
teaches us. And this brings to us a a
question brings up a question and that
is
that is in front and written ahead of
every chapter in the Quran except for
one. 113 times it is repeated and 114th
time in surah.
Is it a verse of the Quran? Is it not a
verse of the Quran? Is it the opening
verse of every chapter? Is it not the
opening verse of every chapter? A
question that the scholars of Islam have
discussed.
But the most important thing for us to
understand in trying to understand this
issue is what did the companions
write in those original
that were sent out by
man in his time. actually if we back
up we see that in the time of Abu Bakr
that was the first time that he
commissioned
he along with
to collect all of the Quran in order and
put it into one book.
And this was done by Zadbin Fabit in the
first two years after the prophet's
death sai wasallam. So by the year 112
we had the first complete musf. This mus
was kept by Abu Bakr. When he passed
away he passed it on to Omar.
And when Omar passed away, he put it in
the care of Hapsah, who is the prophet's
widow.
And when
became the Khalifa, he commissioned
Zenit a second time along with three
others of the companions from Mecca. And
he had them take from that original musf
of Abu Bakr and write four, five, six up
to seven mah that were written and
collected from that original mus of Abu
Bakr.
This is this these seven or eight or
five. It's a difference of opinion how
many there were. But these mah which
were no less than four and no more than
eight
they were
referred to as
these were referred to as the mus ofman
because they were produced by his
command.
These were sent out to the main
capitals of the Muslim Empire at the
time. So, one was sent to Iraq,
one was sent to Al Bahrain, one was sent
to Hashem, one was sent to Yemen, one
was kept in Medina, one was sent to
Mecca. Others mention another a second
that was sent to Albas.
And so these mus became the reference
for any mus ever written afterwards.
And so anyone who wants to write a after
that will always draw from what
the companions had a very particular set
of criteria
in writing this mus of
they agreed
that we will write nothing in this mus
that is not a verse from the Quran.
So in this maf there were no numbers
written. There were no additional
unnecessary lines. There was no patterns
that were written. There were no
there were no you know symbols that were
written between the verses. It was just
the Quran. Why? So that it would not be
confused. that anyone who draws from it
would not be confused because anywhere
you open in these mah the only thing
that was inked
was the Quran the words of Allah
and we see that
was written ahead of every single
chapter except for surah TBA
surah TBA
comes right after surah
The companions
knew that these two chapters are so
closely linked
that
some of the companions held the opinion
that they were the same chapter.
Also surah
was a chapter that Allah had not begun
withman
due to the subject matter that the
chapter began with it made it
inappropriate to have
at the very beginning in that way. So
the companions wrote a line between alf
witha
and left it there at that way. So we see
that the companions who said and agreed
they're only going to pen
in these mah what is the words of Allah
they wrote
ahead of each chapter but this doesn't
mean that
is necessarily part of every chapter
it only means that it is a verse of the
Quran it was written in the same ink. It
was written in the same in the same
script as the rest of the mus. And so
the correct opinion, the opinion of a
large majority of the scholars of Islam
is that
is an independent verse
that is revealed by Allah to mark the
beginning of a chapter and the end of a
previous.
In a
saidchech.
[Silence]
and so Iban Abbas tells us that every
time Allah wished to start a new surah,
he would send withman
and by that they would know this is the
beginning and the end. But notice how
even though we are to get to begin
reciting the Quran with
that's not what Allah began with in that
cave on that night with
he began rather with
recite in the name of your Lord.
That was very important because
bismillah in the name of Allah
it doesn't establish a connection
between
Allah and the prophet sallall.aii Wasam.
But when he says,
so here he says, "Recite and seek aid in
your endeavor of recitation in the name
of your Lord, oh Muhammad." He is your
Lord. It is now what? Intimate. It is
now special. It is closer for him. It
articulates the meaning that Allah is
going to guide your tongue and guide
your heart because he is your Lord. He
is not just Allah. He is Allah and the
Lord of everything generally but he is
specifically your Lord, oh Muhammad. And
he is going to guide your recitation. So
when you recite,
begin your recitation in seeking aid in
the name of your Lord, the one who has
created all of the creation generally
and created the human being
specifically.
This articulates what? This articulates
the honor and the nobility of the human
being. You're different. You're not like
any other creature on this earth. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala created everything
and he created the human being.
And so the human being warrants a
repetition of Allah's creation and
action. Why? Because of the high
standing of the human being. It's as if
Allah is saying he created all of the
creation, but the human being, he's
special. He created the creation and
then he created the human being
and entered the human being into the
remainder of that creation. We will end
therefore this evening. We ask Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala that he teach us
what will benefit us and that he benefit
us from what he teaches us. We ask Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
that he teach us the recitation of his
book that he purify our hearts and
chests and make our hearts and chests
and souls
pure enough and worthy to carry his
words and the meanings of his names and
attributes.
[Arabic recitation]
Walls happy he edge.